so today we are going to talk about how
we code and romantic euro HS oh I have
to confess this one of my favorite
because okay some people may think
although I thought there very few of
them okay
in the early years of chess they
sacrificed everything and there a lot of
very famous game they didn't have much
of idea I think it's basically did the
opposite they were incredible players
and how should should we and why we
should study study these players and how
we should tie their games so the first
games which I think you should start
analyzed are from from the 19th century
and there there was a lot of incredible
players from the 19th century we are
still a little bit early before the the
let's code of the first official world
champion was tiny sighting in 1886 there
was like the the chair genius Paul
Murphy who went to Europe defeated
everyone only start intent want to play
with him this was in 1858 and got back
and never played the game and there were
before him incredible players which were
known for example understand he is known
for a lot of games like the immortal
game the evergreen game but I really
know by my memory some of incredible
games of his which are very very modern
games like one with Leo and Tao I can
even reproduce it by a by memory it's
incredible game positional sacrifice of
peace a very modern attack but also him
morphine and some other players like Lou
espousing Lou espousing not only played
the thousand clearly in the famous line
the zillion but maybe it's not known
that he also played the Dragons he was
the first good player who started
playing the actual dragon in its pure
form with d6 96 in g6 like the game I've
measured just to tell you one curious
thing between anderson and xi tau
joking xi also other professional chest
he had to emigrate from Hungary around
48 and 49 came in USA and then in 1851
he established himself in in Great
Britain way these guys not only were
incredible just pairs with out of ideas
how you see they really knew what it
meant you know the words honor and to be
honest like so I'll show you games in
which you can judge by yourself how many
of the ideas and they produce were
really in a very modern and they're used
even nowadays so one of the ideas our
show in the in the first game and not
only in one game just a couple of maybe
a week ago in the world rapid
championship amount use it to score a
very convincing victory in the Italian
and I'm going to show this game between
parson and Paul Morphy and also I'm
going to give you some additional
information because really these guys
produce a lot of ideas and many of their
ideas are still used very frequently by
the best chess player so the game
started efore e5 Knight f3 Knight 693 no
pausing he used to play the four Knights
openings or used to play off the Scotch
quite in my opinion modern openings and
he played them quite well I remember
some of his games with exceptional
technique sometimes he was a little bit
too solid but very very good player well
more free and of course was out of this
league knock is like chess genius and
this is not only my opinion and even
Bobby Fischer considered that more fees
incredible player all right there is no
doubt about that
so here more he played Bishop c5 and
this line after a couple of years like
13 years he began to play here parson
the most principled Knight takes 25
which at the beginning of the 20th
century kappa blanka used in three games
to to score three victories and of that
he made only one drawing simultaneous
game he also had a big advantage so 95
he is the principal move and there is
one curious game which you can even
found it if we have some odd occasion
I'll show it quite curious between
parson and understand it was played in
their match in 1877
so the
your thing about this game that they
played night x.25 and the line with d4
he got Wow in this game precise key
didn't get opening a transcript played
some very strange move so after 95 95 d4
Bishop d6 take when if I bishop takes 25
he played 95
all right here Bishop d3 in one of these
game because Keith Scott when started
playing 95 is caught the guests
understand precisely 3 victories and 1
loss in this game which also ended with
his victory he played 95 which is not a
good move but what is curious about this
game this is a very unique game because
between the 13 and 12 move the 39 and
the 20th move excuse me understand
played in this 8 move 7 moves with his
rook which I mean I really don't
remember a game like that so he played
rookie 6 Ruby 6 root before rookie for
rue cage for oak aged 5 and we included
in one moment a 6 so it was a little bit
too much but it also shows you know the
great imagination right in this game if
this was too much but you can see it and
hit this game he got a good opening
position but they had left a little bit
you know but or maybe he was enjoying
himself because mm you know this was
like the end of his career he died in
1879 so this is a very in a very curious
effect so after starting this pigeon he
started to play the most principled
person and Knight x.25 Wow in this game
he didn't play in that he played Bishop
b5 d6 d4 Knight takes d4 Bishop d7 now
the opening well went you know quite
alright nothing surprising here white
played natural moves until certain
moment you'll see Queen f6 biomorphic
Castle 97 and now follows the move we
wait it's an obvious place no mistake
but we don't have to be in so fast
because it's much more interesting how
more he played after that well Bishop e3
in almost all of you here in Horn all
that it's a positional mistake because
it makes doubled pawns and one of the
details about the reports they are not
only by themselves a weakness but the
squares in front of them are weak
squares
the square on e5 becomes a real like an
eternal square for the night and if this
night happened to be exchanged there'll
be another piece going on the fight
and when this square is weak well there
it's much easier to transport your
pieces the person only for an eatery are
quite you know easy prey and also the
communication between the pieces is
damaged now you can transfer for example
the rook from d1 you can play route d3
rook on the King side because there is a
pony tree and when there is a blockade
on the square e 5 it means that ok you
have like always very difficulties what
I want to show you in this game is the
incredible plan in which Murphy
demonstrated in this game which was
showing great exceptional feeling about
the dynamics of the game because from
the opening he got an advantage but
instead of playing like solidly like
many today contemporary very good test
will play he played in an exceptional
manner and it's quite interesting that
the team he the first game which I
remember seeing in this team have that
was used by the biggest name in the
chess world not only like I told you
like like a week ago an ant used it also
it was used by Kramnik in the 2018
candidates tournament - to make like
incredible novelty against onion on the
seventh month of g8 against h3 also it
was used in a similar pawn structure by
the incredible genius Bobby Fischer
against a structure in which the pawn
was on some kind of a hedgehog structure
and he makes King each one Luke G 1 G
for Ruby Ruby one because the hoop there
was a pawn on f6 oh it is reverse curse
upon f3
we have this plan after that it became a
standard one from the dis hedgehog bone
structures but most surely Fischer saw
this plan from the the genial hand of
morphe so Bishop e3 well nowadays almost
nobody will play that so now you have a
better pawn structure with right so
probably you should play I just put here
a couple of logic
moves like this one you know to get out
of the pin and play positionally trying
to restrict the the enemy pieces like
this kind of moon sneaks logical to me
knowing White has more space and because
of the correspond structure black should
be you know having having problems but
we should not have this incredible play
by ma thief he passed Indian pain Bishop
III so Bishop III takes Queen h6 until
now everything quite quite easy to
understand rupee 195 Queen ito Castle h3
and now if he just doesn't play very
dynamically of course and black is
better by the way he's not a questioning
if he's better how is going to do
something because okay yup the opponent
probably will try to exchange this
knight on e5 and he'll be rude but okay
maybe the bishop will go to beat me he
has some counter play on the half-open a
foul so he can to consider the dynamics
of the patient which for me is like
astonishing the way he he played even
because we have to be very sure about
the dynamics so here follows for your
surprise using the the pawn hook on on
h3 an incredible of King h8 which after
this move you already gets the idea the
idea will be to use that an opponent h3
as a pawn hooking to attack the the
White King one of the factors which will
help him is the problems with this
double pulse will be the lack of
communication so you see you don't have
you don't have the the third-ranked know
to communicate and also some some of the
squares are much more difficult to be
accessible by the white piece so of
course white rack in the most natural
way they have to you know the exchange
is night when if I if not they are just
attacking with an extra piece no because
the bishop on a4 and it's a very
interesting history of the name because
you have to do it precisely now until
the bishop on a voice do not you know
doing a little bit something more more
useful now so King h8 an ID 1g 590 faith
ugh now it's not possible to prevent g4
because okay if you do it like G
oh I'll play Queen h4 oh yeah
show you here some lines like here and
then rocky anyway the whole position
seems like you know you don't get
anything to move even I have ideas no
later like rook J Luke f6 if you try
mechanically to put something like a
physical barrier in front of the the G
poem then of course the problem is it
you remain with a very bad piece now and
on g4 is hanging so basically this is
like in my opinion resign my position
known terrorists like the eternal night
on 85 so he played 93 this was the idea
to exchange his Knight g4 so you see
judging the dynamic spec television his
exchange his knight on e5 he is getting
poor structure at least not not better
than than the the white pawn structure
but his pieces get the the necessary
activity and just at the right moment
because white knit one no temple to have
the bishop on b3 and to start you know
creating some kind of a counter counter
taken to have appeal to defense so it's
about one temple but it's you know this
incredible feeling of the game to use
this plane in this pigeon because if you
get back a little bit when he's out this
plane no you can't like the personal
comfort now you have a knight on e5 and
now you can play a rookie a rookie 7 who
can I mean try just recently to press
but no he played in a very original way
and that's why I think at least my
respect to this guy and there's more
freezing because I've seen so many ideas
in their games and in of course I very
famous game by Anderson de moto I've
even had the chance maybe some other
lecture you see to play almost identical
ideas as the immortal game sacrificing
abortive rooks
so nowadays we always use the ideas of
this guy because they were the pioneers
and they're really incredible players I
I will never get tired to repeat that so
night x.25 well of course here
you can just take on g4 because Knight
takes on g4 and
you know around the White King it's
really nice oh you
have to exchange in this night take here
detection if I now no more like you see
here in the notes weak square so now you
have to to find a way to sustain the
attack all right no need to look at many
lines here I I've tried to find some
some kind of defense for white but it
was really really difficult so if you
try some kind of a blockade like okay
you can even put here let's say King h2
but of course the dynamic resolution
allow them to play not a very difficult
sacrifice no Ruby III is not too
difficult so Ruby 3 and now okay he's
threatening room g2 and if you accept
Bishop h3 also is going away there is
even a better a better move like this
one you see and now you can do anything
about the Queen g3 no this is like the
big problem in debate the big problem is
it not only the rook is hanging but this
threat Queen g3 is even better than just
to you know to take the exchange and to
have some although not not very big
technical difficulties know if you play
like Queen f3 trying to get some kind of
a you know defense then he still doubles
on the G line to Bishop g4 Queen g6 in
the pressure is too much and the
pollination triste snow in the other
post now we can see the weak pause now
the pawn on e4 in a this precise moment
is weak and it has to do with the fact
of the bishop on a for the bishop if it
also on b3 is to has time to to create
something but it's not there so it's
very good feeling about the moment so he
took on g4 a bishop takes on g4 and are
an incredible move which over the boat
is not easy at all many players here
will be happy to play Bishop h3 the
obvious move now which gives him the
chance to exchange Queens and although
this seems like a bad end game well it's
not as bad as it is it may look take a
little bit of time to to look at it well
here the natural move now you doubled
looks but it has this defense and it
turns on it kickin kickin continue the
play one important detail
is that you can play the rook from 8 to
g3 because then she can take on a strain
oh so you can even lose the game No so
although the the Rukh ending here at the
bishop Isaac Bishop b3 is quite
difficult but you're still in the game
in this precision of morphine and this
few of dynamics you know is like
something to remember because it can be
seen very often in his game very often
so he plays through g6 here putting
everything on the attack and he's always
one tempo down like for example to show
if Bishop b3 now be sure to each tree of
course you don't have Queen f6 anymore
so no Queen exchanges no and after
something like that let me show you now
here I probably didn't continue no
Bishop I said I looked but I looked
first at rookie two to take with the
rook no not to have the problems with
the with the King but still yeah there
was one one tactical hotel just to show
you this move seems a little bit you
know passive but it has a tactical idea
the idea without even moving on the road
is if you take with the rook on f7 he
takes in he has a queen f4 check now
picking up the picking up the bishop and
if not he'll be able to play f6 no and
because the situation of the King you
can never create even a threat you know
on g8 and then of course q stabilize his
material advantage and if you play with
the with the bishop there was like
quintet Rooney fo and you tied up and
very soon he has additional resource you
start putting the de pawn and then you
can do anything against so many
you know threats it's not only the Queen
but then in the eight ball and this will
be like the end so here person to
connect seven Bishop e6 well it's a very
good sign when you play strong moves
with temple this is always a very good
sign of your ideas and this case not
only mentioned here by me I've seen it
in many books so this is like a good
sign of your play
so Bishop e6 and now I put this like
question mark but already you know the
situation was quite difficult
still it was better because it needed
from from black to find one good move
I'll show you now to play Queen f3 and
after Bishop h3 it looks that everything
here is clear and you can cash you know
cash on the victory with Bishop g4 and
with material advantage but I taught
that here having in mind who is playing
with black you can find the move Queen
h4 because it does not allow any kind of
simplification because if you play that
or a Bishop g4 immediately well after
this move let me show you here well this
endgame you have change to survive and
not bad once at or no not much material
some absolutely sure that more fuel not
have gone into that cute get played here
the move Queen h4 why now you understand
why this move is quite unpleasant
because you can show the g3 square so
you can show more squares and now Bishop
g4 is a is a very unpleasant threat so
basically you don't have anything to do
against you know and it's a very
important detail that you can run
because the second rank is vitally
weakened no after this the energy of the
the black piece is obvious and it's
obvious who is who is out of job not the
bishop on a foe who's really has to be
fight he's not doing much help no so
basically black was attacking with an
extra piece so here after he plays
Bishop b3 I play Bishop g4 and because
you can play you you can play Queen g3
and take when 85 well this is already a
technical position not and not not not
really difficult because you are not
only with me Oh dice got all of your
pieces on a passive stent no so this so
in the game he played Queen c7 probably
missing missing just the tactical shot
but the pressure was so much in power
sent away he was a very solid player but
was not like a and great tactician
so here after win sound he just missed
the simple combination which gave the
game even more the more flare yeah no I
hear he's getting check made by very
simple measures no here okay
fate o if you reside on Queen h2 what I
eat should end it in a very simple
checkmate so you see this very original
idea and you think okay maybe he
produced one this idea
nope he followed his own idea in the
match with understand you know I'm not
going to show the whole game but just to
see the idea he played the same idea in
a even more original position and this
is like he played the idea to use the in
the pawn to kinesics with the bishop on
the long table now by black so let me
show you this game because it's rather
impressive so in this match
we in 1858 wow it was quite curious that
after not having very good opening
position understand start to play and he
paid in three matched up of the three
games of the of this match the first
move can you guess which first move and
the same played against more fear of the
keys starting having bad result a three
in three games which is that if you
think about it it's not like something
impressive but in maybe open it's not a
bad move so you can play you're playing
virtually we do be black but he can't
play against you the Spanish the real
opus he plays the Italian okay you have
Bishop a2 or Bishop a7 with reverse card
when were in one temple or so in many
openings for example morphine
we got decent patient but he played the
game scheme like if I've chief when they
played the Sicilian and he had an extra
tempo which is also quite normal for
white know in with a tree although in
the game human she also get some some
problems in the patient he's caught 50%
so he lost one game one draw and one one
so this game I just want to show you how
he used this idea and then quite
surprisingly or maybe not because I I
already told these were great players
understand uses the same idea which
Murphy shot him to him in one
simultaneous game for me it was a great
revelation to find this absolutely
forgotten game in which understand uses
the idea which which he saw by Murphy
used against him so what were the second
test when he use it
so the opening was the
the Scandinavian in one of game for this
match we played Queen takes one d5 93
and he was quite heavily demolished
because okay the open games in the
technical field and the whole feeling of
the chess game for Morphy was incredible
so this was a rather nice game this game
tried 96 d4c for 93 he gave quite early
the pair of Bishops you see NY has more
space here but still the plan which he
employed that's why I'm showing you the
game was really something not easy to
come up so this is like the prison in
which morphic comes up with a very
difficult you know plane to to exercise
but he already had employed similar idea
now so he has a pair of bishops but
black is quite solid is not obvious how
why should proceed no and he comes with
the very original it may be that the
most aggressive plan because really if
you look at the pigeon there is not like
a an obvious plan now you can just play
in this entering change pieces because
then the question of your pawn structure
which is worse with the diode pawns
so you have to play for the pair of
bishops but still the position of black
is very solid not the bishop is on the
long you know so how are you going to
use the hook on a six it seems like a
joke now I mean it can be used no well
he found here a similar plan which we
already use in a very original one so he
plays a h3 now he prepares to put the
King on a square when he uses the fact
that the dark squared Bishop of the
opponent is exchanged so that the king
will feel quite safe or on h2 also it's
a very original there because it's
usually not not so easy to start pushing
the pawns in front of in front of your
king
oh wait for more fee this was something
which was not too difficult and he came
up with this very original play so
th-though rubgy won and now we already
know his idea he wants to play G fo g5
and start attacking and using the pair
of bishops and in the power of the
bishops in open position in the very
important fact that the open doesn't
have
well visual which means that his chances
to become a really problematic and
really weak on the dark squares are much
much higher
No so with this incredible plan he got a
big advance well g5 maybe you know you
say okay he's weakening his King yet but
hey I mean what do you have post of the
plant you want g5 from Jeff a group g1
and the text keeps building up where is
your account to play so that's why you
know it's easier to criticize but it's
for me it was difficult to come up with
something good here for black g5f tall
and already we know that he has like the
initiative no he's opening the position
here maybe and he could get played I put
like a better move but for me from these
games I take you know the this
incredible ideas so he played Rudy 893
anyway now it's obviously he had a tag
after that it was a little bit a long
game because you know what he could have
just won technically more fee but still
to see this idea employed in this very
original position for me was something
very very special and even a little more
interesting for me was to see how
understand employed against the weaker
part in simultaneous the same idea with
that crushing result and then maybe I
can even show you how like it all like
in a very contemporary game and I used
it and not against a weak upon it was in
the world rapid championship and it was
against a grandmaster with 25 something
and boy he crushed him completely so
let's see how understand learn from this
ideas of Murphy and how he employed them
by himself
now there is one game here by Anderson a
very short one because I repeat it was
by the simultaneous but you can see the
idea in a very clear from so Bishop c4
Bishop c5 the Italian Castle Knight f6
understand with black D 693 h6 this is
one of the few occasions when this move
has a good prophylactic value because he
doesn't want you know I don't want to go
in too deep about athe double Bishop g5
Bishop take on f6 95 c3 this in the in
the
was played like a bug and grandma stinky
of it just need to solve it for for
white so this is one of the very few
lines in the in the Italian when let's
let's imagine even here let me show you
so after ninety three on the fraud move
let's say here ninety-six d3 another
place here a six like in d6 is also
solid but on d6 what I don't like is
very much about blacks opening choice
here although this that one of the most
natural moves that why have two options
one of them is more modern correcting
used to play here Knight e4 Bishop d6 a
tree and he exchanges B should just at
the moment Keating is the most fortune
and he keeps his Bishop on on c4 alive
well maybe not enough one I think but
interesting idea and the one which i
think is very solid for for white does
not give them real advantage but I don't
like to play especially this line is
with black this this was used by a
grandmas team in Bulgaria quite often c3
and he'll and black has some problems to
you know to get out of this very solid
scheme no there is a theoretical 97 so
the main idea is that if you play a six
because the way you have a pair of
bishops here this is true but he got
very good control of the center and
kicking even include rooks you won so
look see one here is it you don't have
time to play Bishop g4 because he can
play Bishop take on a six so he wins a
little bit more time off it doesn't give
you any me a chance to put the pin on g4
I start attacking the dark squares which
is the logical you know idea because the
dark squares are weakened by the
exchange of the task red visual so this
is what I'm showing this because this
one of the lines in which very rarely I
like to play it here the matrix which is
considered one of the main theoretical
move so h6 and I don't allow you Bishop
Bishop g5 in the idea on Bishop III you
play Bishop b6 and you want to take in
direction the the standard direction
towards the center know if you place
like here or I played e6 if you exchange
it with a knife then I'll take with a
pawn I'll play
p6 I have the half-open file this had
been considered quite a good position
for for the black amount played with
Kramnik maybe four or five days ago this
position so you see that they play in
this line he played a six also a very
solid move 95 eight six and then he
proceeded with d6 Bishop a7 Bishop e6
still not castling just to see what
white is going to do well it has to do
without a game because let's let's get
back to the game from a simultaneous in
Rotterdam in in Netherlands probably it
was dead because Rotterdam i think is
Nederland and he played 96 d 3 d 693 his
opponent h6 well we know that there was
a difference in strength in this in this
game but still to see the same team here
if you have to be objective to the next
morph is a mistake here it's better in
my opinion objectively to play 94 94 and
try and you know to to exchange this
bishop when the bishop goes to b6 then
you can play for example issue it has to
be sure that you can exchange this
bishop not if you place like let's say
bishop d fo now still your plate c3 I'm
not going to you know to exchange for
from my knight and to to get my knight
on a 4 so this is like an if you place
let's say oh yeah I'll show you on the
boat let's say we play Knight e4 and you
play this pin which probably was he was
preoccupied well you can play here I can
exchange take and now from position or
point of view in my opinion the best
move is to play like Bishop b5 trying in
order to create you know disposition or
threat to make your pawns quite weak so
let's say we play 26 only now I'll play
h3 now I would like you know to exchange
you know this B if it's possible well it
may not be possible but at least here it
will be without the dark square Bishop
the whole team which we've seen in the
game will not be possible but his
opponent played here h3 very similar
you'll see - the very one contemporary
game of heaven and h3 and
now you understand that unless on not
only and played with morphe but he
learnt a lot from from these matches
there follows g5 very very modern move
because now how do you react on g4
nowadays it's well known it's difficult
because even if you play Knight H to his
to plays G fo and then he plays rook J
and starts attacking you know let's let
me show you if you even if you take with
a piece play here through Jade and
because you can play f3 because of this
bad Bishop on c5 he starts taking you
and then he'll castle on the long side
and he already side the attack when wife
you start the attack well maybe some
other game no not in this one so this is
like one of the situation when you have
Castle prematurely which is it's
premature not in itself but because you
have created the so-called pawn cook
team and he uses against it and like I
told you it can be seen you know now
they seen in quite a few interesting
angle after g5 I get told if it tries 92
I play g4 and if you take with the pole
I pay Ruby it and I start attacking like
one example you play here I take bishop
takes on g4 nitration g4 and my attack
is going to develop how you're going to
defend against it it's not very clear
it's not like a immediate you know
fiasco but it's much easier to play this
patient with with black in my opinion
well here the opponent of I'm different
in DC more tennis game side okay I had
enough of this Bishop on c5 so I'm going
to exchange it but we already have the
the pawn hook so the attack is going to
develop quite smoothly g4 very important
moment if you take now on c5 I can even
take the take first on f3 which have
that I'll take on g2 and it's very hard
to believe it you can survive with this
kind of a king no like so likely I take
here with the tempo no then take on g2
and oh yeah I mean the outcome of the
opening is not really impressive so he
took on g4 Bishop takes from g4 take on
c5 and now because 94 is a really an
unpleasant threat at least it covers the
square default
d 6 and straight out of the opening
because this the 11th move it's clear
that white position likes any kind of
productive ideas she's going to castle
is going to play rook Jade and probably
very soon is going to have an easier
tech he said that can be held by
doubling on the G file by pushing the
h-bomb where you're going to write with
the King becomes in my opinion our
mystery
so here and there was like a clear
difference in the strength of these two
chess players so Bishop e3 Castle now
the rest of the game was just pure fun
for understand now king h1 I gave it as
a weak move but it's still the occasion
I really can suggest something probably
the patient is very bad I don't see any
something kin
so at least I understand that he wants
to get out of the possible pitch on the
G line but it's not helping much uga not
the only move because of the situation
of the king here can be helped you know
just to play 97-95 and then he's taken
gy if you're opening even the H file
which will be even a more unpleasant
checkmate but he played it in a rather
casual way you know rook g8 and after d4
he started collecting everything now
here Queen g6 we should be 3 Queen h5
and ok the rest is just you know it was
a simultaneous game but still the idea
which he employed was quite quite
impressive so when we talk about about
understand let me just show you here by
memory I think in game in 1851 the same
year which he played the Amato again
because in the next year he played the
so called evergreen game in the in the
Evans so this game was played with a
rather solid opponent Levin Tao which
law in town we already mentioned him he
lost with all the same result against
morphine oh and he has caught some
victories in one tournament at the end
he won against understand
I don't remember do you and he won the
tournament I mean this was not the only
tournament human oh he was a solid
player but this game is rather impressed
others and also with white against
elemental
they play the traditional in a rather
good and very interesting line the
popular the ever-popular
Evans gambit well nowadays of course we
know more but still the game has a
rather modern feeling so t3 and now
Bishop a5 the most solid defense not the
only one
d4 one okay it was before last scale
invariant here the positional defense
with d6 which is probably the most saw
it no d6 and the idea of d6 is that you
know they even immediately ready to give
up the pawn okay to give up the pawn
back on this move but to have a
comfortable endgame with that the pawn
structure know this oh this is not a
lost endgames wide but away it's a quite
a pleasant one for black this was which
the idea which the second world champion
was Kerr came up and okay last kill you
know made the chess to progress even
further no because if we compare the
first in the in the second world
champion let's talk just a little bit of
them well
Stein's was the first guy couldn't set
it down or some kind of a ruse which
sometimes we have to follow well he was
a rather principled guy that sometimes
he didn't follow the rules because in
Evans in the match which going he played
a couple of position opening pigeon in
his court like 50% in which if you look
at the patient you have a very strong
desire to resign immediately meaning all
the pieces were on the back rank but
because he considers it a matter for all
he played this position so he was quite
indented but away sometimes he get out
of his people but he understood that
there are some principles the
traditional game but the first world
champion asked him to ask you when with
the with the chess match first because
he understood the chess is much more
complex that sometimes you have to play
in a different way that there is not
only one good move the data interesting
many interesting ways to play a position
he was much more flexible and much more
universal player oh that's why just
progressed so let's get back to to our a
game which I want to show you so it
takes on d4 play elemental and now
Castle well here of course there so many
famous game like details on c3
queen bee tree I know even one very
almost like till the end of the game one
line with Queen f6 very interesting of
course Fischer time the friend of the
game which fine was cross was in this
line know it 93 96 95 it's a very famous
game because it's the Fischer 60
memorable games well in our game
Lowenthal played a very solid line so
that's why the game is very interesting
he played d6 takes from d4
understand bishop basics no no let's
take just a little bit a second twist
what would you play here with white
because the next move which is in paid
short how versatile player is because
he's mostly known for all of his
sacrifices I just forget to mention that
he invented so many chess problems to
understand Muslim rather rather creative
guy so here what should we play if you
play Knight g5 I hope you play Knight h6
and then we finish development I don't
get problems on the square d4 know and
in this game obviously he didn't want to
develop his Bishop on Beto because then
the composition is not so obvious if we
try to play like let's say Queen b3 the
problem is that he can play Knight a5
and now if you take 1 X 7 King f8 and we
can defend the bishop no the only square
is on d5 make you play knight of section
we may resign now we are losing a piece
so he came up with the idea to make a
prophylactic move in this precise moment
make a sacrifice a pawn in the opening
because even he's a very sharp line but
we conceded he wanted to develop this
Bishop on g5 not on beetle and and he
comes with this prophylactic move h3
which does not allow you know to be
pinned the knight on f3 so the there
will be not possible to you know to
exploit some weakening on the d4 square
and also not only a professional but
awaiting he waits for night 96 and to
play Bishop g5 well here hello at our
play tonight at 6
Bishop g5 and this is my and probably
okay not not Bishop g5 so I I told you I
know it but memory Bobby Bishop g5 here
will be premature and of course
understand plate a much better move
because you play now Bishop g5 you have
time for h6 and now he can use the
already mentioned team now you can play
g5 here and after Bishop g3 you have a
rather pleasant choice now you can play
g4 using the the pawn hook team on h2 or
you can even take the pawn like as I'm
seeing here on the boat I can just caso
I'm going to take here defy him
okay it's hard to believe it you're not
much worse out of the open though
because you're not only down in material
but some of your squares like the light
one you're not going to exist no 96 he
played Knight e3 and here one of the
very few of mistakes will go and tell
mate in this game because it was like a
difficult game he should get paid also
not an obvious at all in my opinion
reflective move h6
it seems so no because they've played a
sharp line against you in 86 kinda does
not look natural but you want to avoid
the bishop to go to g5 now at least if
the bishop goes to a tree well he can
have some kind of ideas like a five you
know you can go with your piece a little
bit on a more passive position but then
you want Bishop f5 you know you have a
solid pigeon you have a an extra pawn
you get some compensation but okay maybe
it's not something dangerous know if you
place like d5 for example here okay oh
no after eight six here he plays d5 here
you can play Knight a5 also you can play
no Knight if I because I don't want you
know after 97 sometimes you know to have
Bishop b2 and to press on on f6 it was
even like in this patient before h3 just
to give you one more data you can play
here d5 let me just show you so now I
think that he would have played Knight
a5
they did it I don't want if I put 97 I
mean on Bishop b2 I don't want to play a
six now he
a little bit and I don't want of course
to play Knight f6 and to let him take
one exit because then if you have
positional conversation now which I
don't like to have this damaged bone
structure so if you ask me on defy her
playing 95 just because I take to be
shoot and then I want to develop my
knight on a chicken into castle and then
the compensation well my night is on a5
a little bit not assumed but the price
is upon which is okay with me
and if you play something like let's say
check and I push here let's say you take
and you play here to keep me on c6 well
now I can probably even develop on my 27
because if you attack my pawn
I can defend it with Bishop c5 no one I
keep a healthy except allah no and i
don't see what you can really attack so
your compensation is kind of a dubious
one so he played 93 and here Lowenthal
made one of the very few mistakes castle
no a seemingly very natural move now
there are four old Bishop g5 and I
understand well now the pin with the
bishop on b6 is kind of am told to thing
okay you play a six Bishop h4 now he's
threatening 95 so you can you know just
play something
he plays g5 well probably on g5 you know
what he played but this is like the kind
of a sacrifice of g5 when it's not clear
at all no I mean the who is guarding the
d4 square no so it's completely
positional in a very well thought
sacrifice well it has to be made know
so Knight takes from g5 well here take
on g5 is not the only move you can take
bishop on d4 but that I think Knight
takes on f7 take 95 similar motive like
in the game I think he took on g5 Bishop
takes on g5 and now Bishop takes on d4
so for the piece how many points you've
got zero so the deck is completely
position open and it's not obvious at
all well the first more move is obvious
what doing it on the same plate here yes
yeah 95 so you have to keep you on the
pin no 95 now it's very hard to suggest
a much more natural than the move key
plate and I think the multiplayer is the
best one
so you have some help try to avoid you
know this night in d5 so he plays Bishop
e6 it's really hard for me to come up
with something better
so okay Bishop takes one a one he's like
the perfect way to a suicidal mission oh
I mean then you the black pigeon it
explodes immediately no so Bishop e6
here and now let's take a look what do
you thing is here on the same plate just
a little bit how how he proceeded to
attack the gun is not is not obvious no
it's not in he kita very like a toy a
very contemporary idea using the rook
for the famous route Clift and it seemed
kind of it needs some time so he plays
ruby one but still the threat is an
obvious one he wants to be three but
it's not very easy to to to find like an
answer no because the way the the very
important fact is the bishop on d4 is
hanging so if you take on d5 you're not
helping because he takes with the pawn
and then the bishop on d4 is really
hanging no and he wants rugby three Luke
g3 so you know what is going to happen
but the question is how you're going to
react well this was the the only real a
mistake but a hard one
he of course many years of debt we can
say that maybe it was possible but these
a hotline sacrifice the Queen in my
opinion this was the only the only
chance but not not easy at all so Knight
takes d5 probably the only move he'll
take here and you used 93 still these
lines are quite difficult now you can
play one Queen d3 and protect your
bishop but this move let's say queen h5
and then you take on c4 now even this
position is not easy to play here for
example you have to play the King on a
light square because if you play it on
h8 Bishop f6 is with a check now with
the temple and then the knight on c3 is
hanging no you have to play here and
after Bishop f6 you can call on this
pigeon
although even now it's not clear now it
still seems like the the black king is
vulnerable I've analyzed this picture
and I understand and how en they can
hold it but it's not it's not easy you
know so it's like in my opinion not
punished at all to blame here xi tau for
not playing the move like 95 it's a hard
move it's a difficult one and it doesn't
seems to like you know the position is
is beyond control but still he played
here Ruby 8 like defending the pawn and
probably not not seeing like immediate
threat but after Ruby 3 it becomes
evident that the threats are very strong
no because now Luke g3 is like a
terrible threat even if you play and
just let me show even if you play Bishop
e5 the same move is possible it's not
the only one but even you can play on
this one Ruby 3 which shows you know how
strong was this positional idea of the P
sacrifice because if you take now I take
on f6 now with a check and here okay
of course it's essential that if you
take here here and you take he you get
checkmate no because the bishop has to
control the g4 square so here after
after Ruby 3 in my opinion there is no
possible defense no the end of the game
was was immediate but I don't see how
you react on the rubgy treat right know
he played King age 7 and after Bishop
take on f6 very simple finish now very
easy one bishop take here check on h5 if
you go to g7 of g3 is the end no your
skill night take on f6 and here
eleventh-hour resigned
although ok let me show just one line
because it's accurate let's say you take
I give check you play Queen g7 and ok
now if you take the Queen give check
tycoon e6 it's an easy technical pushes
I mean this one should be an easy one
let's say check let's say take here and
play a forehead it's a loft Allah
solution there is no doubt but my
question to you just to to make a little
bit of an exercise in this position can
you find something even one planet which
which I like something which includes
the
on f1 in a very curious way so what
other move you can play here except take
in the real Queen yet yeah yeah but I
mean let me show you this this
interesting idea so you can even play
using the pin Queen h6 forcing him no
forcing him to this half has to take you
know you take and now even the rocker f1
starts playing which can be seen like if
you take here I give you a check and now
of course if you have time you can start
pondering do I play a rookie for a
player or give six the good thing is
just not to waste all of your time
because it's the same this game in my
opinion has a very contemporary feeling
and ok somehow I can go maybe even if
you want today I can show you at least
without knowledge just to see one game
which was played like a premiership on a
nun so it was played
let's see now it's like a couple of
weeks like two weeks maybe ago or maybe
three weeks now and I'll tweet with a
grandmaster with 25:14 so the same pawn
hook team let's see
and okay all of this has been played
before but still the game is quite
impressive no using the the the Pau hook
team let me show you this game from the
world record championship Bishop a7 and
rh3
this has been played before it's not
it's a inaccuracy in this moment not
because it can be used the fact that you
create a pawn cook and black is not
castle because of a black as castle very
rarely you can start pushing the pawns
in front of your king well pause more we
could do it but oh you get the special
circumstances just to invent incredible
idea and also the opponent even have the
pair of bishops now he didn't have
control of the dark square so you can
hide his King on h2 here of course if
black is Castle you don't push
h6 in g5 because you know it can be
considered like a complete complete can
we cut this tile now but I hear a nun
play to 86 this mission the I deal with
g5 has been placed even after 92 which
is slightly better version for for white
but still and unpleasant position so g5
wow this was an apparent surprise but
this is not like an
new idea it has been played and here the
whole game and unplayed not only very
well but in some moments keep he played
very solidly he was completely winning
and he didn't want to give him not even
a chance in one moment he had a very
simple sacrifice of Queen and he saw it
I'm sure but you know just because the
previous time I I talked with you about
the greatest knowledge so you you can
learn from these guys to be practical
because he's such a incredible technical
player now but then I hit everything on
a plate he didn't want to play for some
spectacular effects no she just knew
that everything is done you see the end
of the game so g4 takeaway if you take
on a seven I'll take one f3 so we
already know this from the other same
game no I take on e3 in this moment just
to have night action g4 with a tempo no
okay if you take with a poem I take on
g4 I still have the attack and your
pawns are even worse and what is doing
the rookin only one now this this motive
to take we need to be when the rookies
on e 1 or when the black rookies on e 8
and in the bishop on e6 is a very
typical you know because when he takes
with a pawn he gets 2 years time to move
the rook on the half-open FY Oh No so
Bishop e3 rookie 3 night here Queen f6
and now you just caso long and starts
attacking no and it's it's a rather
natural it's quite cool lately in this
patient in a blitz game a much a much
better player a Chinese Grandmaster at
least immediately sends the danger and
he he tried to run immediately with the
King he still ours position but wait
this makes more sense now starting to
evacuate the King you're still far away
from you know getting success but it
makes sense now in this game in the
rapid thermal he just try to defend here
with pieces but you don't have enough
pieces no Rukia and the attack is
obvious and it resembles quite quite a
bit the game of understand only here the
opponents are slightly different so that
the guy with white is not such a we play
but still you know the same ot so black
is attacking like free and white doesn't
have any play at all so it's not
surprising
they got demolished now so 95 Queen g7
now the attack know if he starts
rattling you know just to to get with an
item and made still way from probably
visually it was difficult here when he
starting just to jump with the night
like 96 and threatening checkmate just
to play a can move like you know Queenie
to he's to a bad position but away when
he's threatening you know just to open
and to tighten your mate just not to
play g3 is difficult no it's still a
strong attack because this one no doubt
it but at least you cannot create it
another pawn hook no but it's it's much
easier to give advice then to play like
that
he played g3 and we already know h5 now
he's creating h4 and after that because
it immediately you sacrifice own f2 can
take you can go to e3 there is no
immediate you know loss but after I play
here if you go to h4 night x1 f2 so he
is attacking with winning all of your
pawns it for free without giving you
anything no so that's why here situation
is completely you know beyond any
control so he played King f1 where we
already know that you know H for the
same mode if you take with a knight
Knight take soon connect to know
complete annihilation took with a pole
now of course Luke age for he saw ok
troll he could have played it but why to
play rook age foreign you know to make
effect no he just continues attacking
position he just open that file and then
put his piece and gifting checkmate and
I don't mean that he didn't play that
further on in the game just a cup of
Musa
you'll see if he has a very easy
sacrifice and he still didn't go for the
tweak and this Anand who sees tactics in
milliseconds no f5 Bishop f5 Ruka fate
everything very natural no Bishop d5 now
Luke f3 he got a playboy why why to
complicate your life I mean no doubt
about that
he played 96 the attack is completely
clear all right this is the moment where
having complete you envision and
sure the kickee shock queen g5 alright
this is not difficult for now at all
Queen g5 and after have to Bishop f3
you got checkmate it no well maybe he
missed it it could happen but the way
the patient was so so winning that there
is even no need
okay just let me so the attack is on the
board the only thing is just not to meet
something very simple so if you take on
h4 to give me the chance to play Knight
f5 well steal your cat's check Bhutto
get the king is going to start running
so he plays a very simple move queen g6
and then the maid is on the board so you
don't need to sacrifice anything no so
that's why here
King e2 or oak aged 4 out this is like
no need to commit now everything is
falling apart and the N is queen h5 here
Nyjah for you know not not giving him a
single chance and here he resigned
because of a the Hokulea one till the
end of the game was you know not doing
anything and deservedly loses all his
pieces in the end no no he got checkmate
ok whatever your one does the same team
in a very in a very recent game and I
think that many of these things is
because we have to give thanks to all
these guys in the Romantic era because
they were incredible incredible players
in not only because of the tactics which
are they mostly renowned because of many
additional ideas because both morphia
understand I've seen many many
incredible pushing ideas from them and
further on when we continue with this
team I'll show you even more because the
way the guys really can play incredible
chests and they have to invent
everything they couldn't you know go and
check with the computer they cou know
they just get o to play it on the broad
and that's why nowadays we have the the
gesso developed because they put the
foundation of all of our knowledge in I
think we have to give them many thanks
for for their contribution to chests and
I hope that they'll never be forgotten
because they really deserve to to always
remember them so thank you
and we'll continue the the next time
[Music]